Transcription: eric vautier
Relecteur: Claire Ghyselen
Le thème de ma présentation, c'est :
« Jugaad, ou innovation frugale :
comment faire plus avec moins ? »
Je montre des frigos, mais rassurez-vous,
je ne vais pas en vendre à des pingouins
mais par contre,
je vais essayer d'en vendre
à des Indiens et des Africains.
Si, moi Occidental, j'essaye de vendre
un frigo à des Indiens et des Africains,
quelle question vais-je me poser ?
Je vais me dire : « En Inde
et en Afrique, il fait chaud.
Qu'est-ce que je vais faire banalement ?
Je vais augmenter
la puissance de mon frigo
pour répondre à leurs besoins.
Les illustrations que je vous montre,
vous les trouverez
dans la philosophie Jugaad.
La première illustration, c'est la réponse
qui a été donnée par des Indiens.
C'est le frigo Mitticool,
un des éléments fondateurs
de l'innovation frugale.
C'est un potier indien
qui a inventé un frigo
à destination du public local.
Gros intérêt : il n'a pas
besoin d'électricité.
Il y a une seconde solution
que j'apprécie beaucoup aussi,
c'est la solution inventée
par les Touaregs,
elle aussi très maligne.
Qu'ont-ils fait ?
C'est évident qu'un Touareg dans le désert
aura du mal à avoir de l'électricité.
Donc qu'ont-ils fait ?
Ils ont en fait utilisé deux jarres,
ils en ont mise une dans la seconde.
Ils utilisent une propriété toute simple :
si on met de l'eau
au soleil, elle s'évapore,
et en s'évaporant, sa température baisse,
et ça suffit à réfrigérer
l'intérieur de l'enceinte
et ça permet à l'utilisateur
de conserver ses produits.
Dans la littérature, on dit qu'ils peuvent
conserver une tomate pendant 20 jours.
Donc ça répond à leurs besoins.
Maintenant, je vais partager
une tranche de vie,
c’est-à-dire ce que j'ai vécu moi.
On va changer de registre.
« Le poids des mots, le choc des photos. »
Rassurez-vous, ça, je ne l'ai pas vécu.
J'ai pris un incident
sur le site du ministère,
un vieil accident.
La photo ne correspond pas,
mais c'est pour vous montrer
ce que peut représenter
un accident de ce type-là.
Que s'est-il passé
sur ce site de stockage de gaz ?
Il y a eu un dysfonctionnement,
et du gaz a circulé dans le tuyau
dans le mauvais sens.
Un classique.
Le problème, c'est qu'il est remonté
dans une chaudière,
que ça a fait exploser.
Selon le site du ministère,
les pompiers ont mis aux alentours
de 45 minutes pour éteindre l'incendie.
C'est un exemple d'accident grave -
je touche du bois,
je n'en ai jamais vécu -
mais en tant qu'ingénieur en maintenance
dans différentes entreprises -
j'ai fait de la pharma,
j'ai fait de la pétrochimie,
j'ai fait de la métallurgie -
j'ai vu des petits accidents.
Et autant comme ce gros accident,
on le traite parce
qu'effectivement il est gros :
on va mettre en place
de la technologie, un capteur,
de l'intelligence,
pour essayer d'empêcher tout simplement
un fluide de circuler dans l'autre sens.
Ça, c'est la vision commune, courante :
gros risques,
grosses solutions techniques.
Mais imaginez un cas plus simple.
Je vais prendre l'illustration
dans une entreprise d'agroalimentaire.
Ils vont mélanger de la confiture
de fraises avec la confiture de coings,
alors qu'on veut des biscuits à la fraise.
Je n'aime pas la confiture de coings,
je ne vais pas les manger.
C'est un cas plus simple.
Une anomalie comme ça va être traitée
à la « va comme je te pousse »
parce qu'il n'y a pas d'enjeu.
On a perdu un peu de confiture.
Mais je me suis dit :
à travers la mise en œuvre
de solutions simples -
la question que je me suis posée
est aussi bête que ça :
je veux empêcher un fluide
de circuler dans le mauvais sens
grâce à une solution simple.
Je me suis mis une contrainte,
comme les Indiens
et les Africains précédemment :
mettre en œuvre une solution
qui n'utilise pas d'électricité.
Ça, c'est l'idée.
Vous faire un cours de mécanique
des fluides n'aurait pas grand intérêt ;
par contre, qu'illustre cette idée ?
Que j'ai mis en œuvre
des solutions mécaniques simples,
qui étaient à la disposition
de tous depuis longtemps,
et que je les ai déformées
et agencées autrement.
Qu'ai-je fait ?
J'ai mis un clapet,
un dispositif mécanique simple empêchant
un fluide d'aller dans le mauvais sens,
mais je ne l'ai pas utilisé
pour assurer cette fonction-là,
je l'ai utilisé comme capteur.
Ça, c'est la première ruse du système.
La seconde ruse,
c'est que j'ai utilisé un défaut -
je ne vais pas aller dans le détail -
et j'ai cherché à amplifier
le défaut de ce clapet
à travers une membrane.
Je vous expliquerai après
à quoi elle sert.
Et ensuite,
pour assurer de manière sûre l'isolation,
donc pouvoir arrêter le produit,
j'ai mis une vanne ou un robinet.
Rappelez-vous ce que je vous ai dit :
je m'étais imposé la contrainte
de ne pas avoir
d'électricité à disposition.
Une vanne - je ne vais pas
vous faire un cours -
ne va pas se fermer toute seule :
soit quelqu'un surveille
ce qu'il se passe dans le tuyau
et la ferme -
ce n'est pas ma solution -
soit je vais mettre
à disposition de l'énergie.
Je vous l'ai déjà dit :
de l'énergie, je n'en ai pas.
Comment ai-je rusé ?
Je n'ai pas d'énergie, mais,
par contre, je vais essayer de la stocker.
Je la stocke dans un ressort.
Tout simplement.
L'astuce de la membrane
que j'évoquais avant,
c'est qu'en fait,
le défaut du clapet que j'ai amplifié -
imaginez un petit crochet
qui va venir se libérer
et qui va permettre
à la vanne de se fermer.
La boucle est bouclée :
j'ai une solution qui est simple.
Qu'est-ce qui se cache derrière ?
Des applications multiples.
Là est l'intérêt de la pensée Jugaad :
à travers la mise en œuvre
de solutions simples,
on ouvre un champ d'investigation
et d'application extrêmement large.
Autre intérêt : on est parfois
tellement noyé par la technologie
qu'on ne comprend plus à quoi ça sert.
Je vous ai fait un cours en deux minutes,
vous avez saisi à quoi ça sert.
Demain, si, dans votre environnement,
dans votre univers industriel ou ailleurs,
un événement arrivait, vous diriez :
« Tiens, il y a une solution toute simple
qui existe, je vais la mettre en œuvre. »
Ensuite, dans la démarche -
puisque ça a été ma démarche.
« J'ai une idée, c'est magnifique,
formidable », on est enthousiaste,
mais il y a quand même un verdict :
on va déposer un brevet.
Un brevet, c'est extraordinaire
parce qu'on fait
une recherche d'antériorité.
La recherche d'antériorité,
c'est la base de données
du génie humain.
Il y a beaucoup d'idées extraordinaires.
Et qu'est-ce que j'ai trouvé
dans cette base de données ?
Une invention, un brevet qui date de 1956.
Globalement l'inventeur a eu
le même problème que moi :
il voulait empêcher un fluide
d'aller dans le mauvais sens ;
il a utilisé globalement la même ruse :
il a bon an mal an utilisé un clapet
pour venir mesurer le sens du fluide,
mais par contre, il a été
moins Jugaad que moi.
Pourtant en 1956,
l'électricité était un peu
moins disponible qu'aujourd'hui.
Il s'est dit : « Je vais utiliser
de l'électricité pour fermer ma vanne. »
Vous avez le brevet de 1956
et celui de 2016.
Le brevet de 2016, c'est quoi ?
C'est un simple croquis.
Je vous le montre.
Vous allez me dire : « Non,
ce n'est pas possible,
c'est trop simple. »
On me l'a dit fréquemment :
« Ce n'est pas possible
que tu aies pu inventer ça en 2016,
ça a déjà dû être inventé avant. »
L'antériorité a prouvé que non.
Et ensuite :
« C'est trop simple,
ça ne pourra pas fonctionner. »
Donc on passe à l'étape d'après :
le prototype.
Là, c'est un peu plus joli
quand même : vue 3D, CAO, etc.
On a travaillé avec une équipe d'étudiants
en essayant de conserver la pensée Jugaad,
c'est-à-dire de se dire
de rester sur un dispositif
qui doit être généralisé,
de se concentrer sur la solution,
de démontrer que ça fonctionne -
les étudiants avaient six mois devant eux
pour faire un truc qui marche ;
ils ont fait un truc qui fonctionnait
et, depuis que la vidéo est publiée,
je dis aux gens : « Regardez, ça marche.
Voilà la preuve. »
Je n'ai pas pu m'empêcher
de citer Bertrand Piccard,
qui est quelqu'un que j'admire énormément
et qui résume effectivement le doute
et le travail que doit faire un pionnier
pour réussir à prouver
aux gens que ça fonctionne.
Les pionniers, au début,
on se moque de leurs échecs.
Quand j'ai pondu ce croquis,
au début, on m'a pris
un peu pour un cinglé,
et puis à la fin,
quand ça fonctionne,
les gens me disent :
« Mais c'est absolument évident. »
J'ai un profond respect pour lui
et je n'ai pas pu m'empêcher
de mettre une citation de sa part.
Le futur.
J'ai montré ce slide et on m'a dit :
« C'est bizarre parce que ton futur
va dans le mauvais sens en fait.
Visuellement, le futur,
on le fait aller [vers la droite]. »
C'est peut-être inconscient mais en fait,
ma vision du futur, c'est qu'on doit
aussi s'inspirer du passé.
C'est peut-être aussi ma manière
d'appréhender les choses.
C'est ce que je disais :
une fâcheuse tendance à sortir du cadre.
Quand tout le monde dit :
« Le futur est par là »,
il est de l'autre côté pour moi.
Mais globalement,
qu'est-ce qu'il s'est passé ?
Il y a trois ans,
j'ai eu l'idée et je me suis dit :
« Je vais y aller. »
J'ai créé une start-up de mécanique.
On parle beaucoup de start-ups,
en règle générale, de technologie,
d'Internet, de choses de ce type-là,
et moi, j'ai créé
une start-up de mécanique.
Suite à ça, j'ai rencontré des gens,
j'ai été accompagné,
il y a des gens qui y ont cru,
et vraiment, ça m'a fait chaud
au cœur d'être accompagné.
Des gens m'ont pris pour un fou
mais je ne retiens que ceux qui m'ont
aidé et accompagné - je les remercie.
Que s'est-il passé depuis ?
A partir du moment
où on a créé un démonstrateur,
on a montré aux gens que ça fonctionnait,
qu'est-ce qu'il s'est passé ?
Il y a six mois environ, j'ai signé
un partenariat avec un fonds souverain
qui va m'aider à promouvoir l'idée.
Et actuellement, je suis en contact
avec des multinationales
dans le domaine
de la robinetterie et des fluides
pour promouvoir cette idée.
C'est une aventure.
Je m'étais dit que c'était possible,
mais je pensais que ce serait autrement,
beaucoup plus modestement,
et en fait, cette aventure,
elle est en train de prendre
un essor extraordinaire.
Et pour conclure,
s'il y avait quelques idées à retenir,
c'est :
face à une problématique,
n'hésitez pas à sortir du cadre.
Parce que quand on sort du cadre,
parfois,
on est amené à proposer des solutions
qui sont redoutablement simples.
Et quand on en propose une,
qu'est-ce que ça implique ?
C'est simple, c'est facile
à comprendre, c'est fiable,
ça ne coûte pas cher,
et donc ça peut être généralisé.
C'est une notion importante.
Et la philosophie Jugaad
nous guide vers des solutions simples.
C'est donc une philosophie
qui a de l'attrait.
Et par ailleurs,
à travers effectivement la mise
en œuvre de solutions simples,
il ne faut pas voir
que l'innovation technologique.
Il faut aussi voir que ça nous projette
dans le monde de demain.
Si demain ce dispositif permet
de préserver l'environnement
et de préserver les ressources,
quelque part, on aura gagné,
on aura fait avancer
et on aura inspiré le progrès.
Je vous remercie.
(Applaudissements)